if you want to see
how deep and long-lasting the current
republican party
delusion or lies depending on what you
think about them
about the 2020 presidential election are
going to last i have very bad news for
you it looks
like the denialism delusion and lies
about the 2020 election are going to
last
for a very long time i have video for
you from yesterday
of top house republican steve scalise
he's the house
minority whip or whip some say
he went on abc's this week he was
interviewed by host
jonathan carl and asked a very simple
question
are you ready to say the election wasn't
stolen
are you ready to say that donald trump
didn't really win
in a landslide as he claims and that joe
biden simply won
he got more votes in enough states to
get more than 270 electoral votes
steve scalise is asked this question
listen to the equivocation
listen to the language choices of steve
scalise
this is almost march we are almost
four months from this election and steve
scalise just won't stop
but clear this up for me joe biden won
the election
he is the legitimate president of the
united states
the election was not stolen correct
look joe biden's the president uh there
were a few states that did not follow
their state laws that's really the
dispute that you've seen continue on and
look
if you're joe biden you probably want to
keep talking about impeachment
and anything other than the fact that
he's killed millions of american energy
jobs
that is a 29 second clip half of which
is and the anchor talking
and still in 15 seconds steve scalise
manages to slip in
look joe biden is the president which is
that's a sort of dog whistle that's code
for
he is the president but he didn't win
understand the careful vocabulary
choices there
scalise says there were states that
didn't follow
their own state laws by which he means
too many people who wanted to vote were
able to vote and nobody stopped them
with the voter suppression that we were
planning
and then he says joe biden would rather
keep talking about impeachment
no he wouldn't joe biden hasn't been
talking about
impeachment since being sworn in every
time biden is asked about impeachment he
says
i'm not involved i wasn't in the senate
when this was uh
done i had nothing to do with the house
vote i'm not getting involved since
impeachment joe biden also hasn't been
talking about it joe biden seems to have
no interest in talking about impeachment
then it continues and jonathan carl
tries again
to get a straight answer that he
continues to
they just signed the paris accord that's
going to kill manufacturing jobs in
america
but at the end of the day when you look
at where we are in this country
either we're going to address the
problems that happen with the election
that people are still millions of people
are still concerned about the
constitution says state legislatures set
the rules for elections
that didn't happen in a few states and
so going forward
look joe biden's president but doesn't
it but i i i mean i mean
towards what people are angry about but
but congressman i know joe biden's the
president he lives at the white house
uh i asked you is he the legitimate
president of the united states and do
you concede
that this election was not stolen very
simple question please
understand once once the elect once the
electors are counted yes he's the
legitimate president
but if you're going to ignore the fact
that there were states that did not
follow their own state legislatively set
laws
once the electors voted he's the
legitimate president
but and and of course there what he
means
is the electors in some states voted
for the person who didn't really win in
some
states biden got the electoral vote
but he hadn't actually won the popular
vote in those states these
are the continued dog whistles there's a
little bit more let's take a quick look
at it
that's the issue at heart that millions
of people still
are not happy with and don't want to see
happen again you know look
you can rehash the election uh from 2020
all day long but
there are people concerned about what
the next election is going to look like
are we going to finally get back
to the way the rule of law works and i
think that's the biggest frustration
many people have
those states that didn't follow the law
are they going to keep doing that in the
future
are we going to finally get back to what
the constitution calls out
for electing our leaders imagine saying
as steve scalise a ranking republican
says that what people want with
elections
is to get back to the rule of law
despite
democrats trump lost claimed victory at
2am on election night
ran a two-month campaign claiming it was
stolen
and that he won in a landslide had
lawyers
try more than 50 legal complaints
none of which went anywhere still
refused to concede
and then incited a riotous insurrection
at the capitol on january 6 and steve
scalise says
we need to get back to the rule of law
we'll talk to your own party
talk to people like josh hawley and
others
it's just stunning and then um oh
it's separately from this same interview
the topic of january 6th
does come up and jonathan carl points
out
trump still hasn't taken any
responsibility for
his role in inciting that riot check out
the mental gymnastics scalise does here
just as difficult to get an answer on
this one but
but wait a minute i mean he hasn't taken
responsibility you heard kevin mccarthy
say i mean do you agree with what kevin
mccarthy
said there that the president must take
responsibility that the facts
demand that he take responsibility for
what happened on january 6th
well first of all i wrote a wall street
journal editorial about
where i think the responsibility lays
for january 6th and surely there's a lot
of
blame to go around but at the end of the
day the people who stormed the capitol
on january 6th
it was a disgrace and they need to be
held accountable in fact over 180
have already been arrested and i know
the fbi is working to root out every
person
who broke into the capital who attacked
police uh there's i mean that's
that's obvious i'm asking about donald
trump's
role in this you heard again kevin
mccarthy do you agree with what he said
that he bears responsibility for what
happened for what happened
again you can go back you can go back
and look at the impeachment trial
the second impeachment trial it seems
like all they've done since
they walked into office was try to
impeach them but again when you look at
that trial
they ran a clip of pretty much every
united states senator who voted to
impeach president trump
who talked about uh things like go and
fight like kell and
other things like that even the simplest
of questions
he will not answer if they would put
any kind of blame on donald trump
he simply won't do it and steve scalise
is
remaining as one of the most steadfast
defenders of donald trump
absolutely no matter what period end of
story so
the messages if you thought they'd stop
defending him any time soon not so
and the reason we care about this is not
because we need to be reminded again
that these people don't care about law
and order
and don't care about the truth or
reality or facts or empiricism or the
world as it actually exists rather than
as they wish that it would be the reason
this matters is that
if they still won't even concede that
trump actually did lose
they aren't going to be um anything but
complete and utter obstructionists
for the foreseeable future which
reinvigorates my thought
that it's time to stop waiting on
republicans for covet stimulus
it's time for democrats to pass it via
budget reconciliation let
every single republican if they want
to vote against it and put themselves at
risk of the electoral consequences
if their uh constituents don't like it
but these are the people we're waiting
around for the guy who still won't say
trump had something to do with the
insurrection and still won't say
trump simply lost these people can't be
counted on for anything and it's time to
just move forward without them